[Music]
[Music]
our mariachi for the Toloache is
different than most varieties were
formed in New York City we're all women
most people think of by the HS being
from Mexico as being men as being macho
and you know we're pretty much opposite
of all those things I started my musical
career playing with a local all-male
mariachi in Brooklyn for me was really
hard to communicate with other male
mariachis because of the machismo
that's very vivid and the culture and in
the genre of mariachi that's kind of why
I wanted to start my own group and that
led for me to do a all-female group
because I didn't want to deal with men
and it's not so much that people say
you're not a MIDI at you but it's the
fact that they think that we cannot play
mad at you because we're women and we're
wearing pens and we have curly hair and
and we don't look Mexican or we don't
have this look that they're expecting
yes
as a women mariachi we're technically
supposed to be wearing skirts and it
didn't work for us that's one of the
most passionate music that I've ever
heard it is just beautiful
it's very heartfelt and I think that's
what makes money actually so special my
dream to be able to perform and connect
with people through music I don't think
I could ask for more that's what keeps
us going
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm a fighter because that's all I've
known how to eat my name is Tanya Smith
and I'm a competitive historical fencer
we train in a system developed by a 14th
century master and practiced until the
16th century we've built a really
awesome community of women and we're all
doing it together I train and teach in
longsword it's my primary weapon I'm 5 2
and my longsword comes up to shoulder
level it's empowering and fun
and use it to cut you could use it to
thrust you can get close and range and
crapple
and really just kick ass with classes
were very very small in the beginning it
felt like I was the only woman and being
the token girl it was something I was
comfortable with at first but as I got
better and as I started developing my
goals as a fighter I realized I wanted
to have a community of other women with
shared philosophies an event I planned
was a women's tournament one of the
first of its kind in the US
people will view openings event as
lesser but I shouldn't have to beat
someone who still with my height or
double my wait to prove that I am a good
fencer the standard should be beating
the best fighters
[Music]
women make good fighters because they
want to be there they put their heart
and souls into it
you don't do this because you're forced
to be there you don't do this because
there's an expectation to be there they
do it because they're passionate about
it
[Music]
seven miles off Estonia's west coast in
Eastern Europe lies the small island of
canoe a bucolic and serene place that
feels lost in time home to just 400
people it functions like one of the
world's few matriarchal societies this
is a place where women roll well mostly
everything come to Ireland my name is
Mariah Anytus I lived almost all my life
in this island our lifestyle is
different comparing the lifestyle in the
mainland many old traditions still our
life
one such tradition is that canoes men
spend months away at sea fishing for the
island meanwhile canoes women are in
charge of leading the community and
preserving its way of life
men were always wrong time away from the
island and something the historical
reason why you may become a very strong
very independent kid no conscience
interesting because we have killer
additional costumes as I everyday
wearing she's making skirts because she
has four granddaughters we have ancient
folk songs still alive and dances they
have a lot of practical skills how to
live all over the year here yes life is
more difficult here to survive it's
treasure for 1000 Islanders they all
described Island that it's like a
paradise it's the best place in the
world we hadn't made let off camera era
an image in her go to her in the ring
gear I got rocked again nice and
employee said Kittleman amis in new a
lot of justice quicker start up a leak
on mostly the clothes the music the
dancing all of it has been recognized by
UNESCO on its intangible cultural
heritage list the keynote rating songs
and many traditions are more than 2,000
years old so this is a main thing why we
are in this UNESCO List
the same list acknowledges canoes women
as the custodians of their islands
heritage I concern everybody that our
unique culture can disappear it's very
valuable if those things still exist and
survived and the modern world it's
really miracle
[Music]
you
[Music]
chemistry explains literally everything
that is happening around us the dryads
is taking the thermal energy from the
water unfortunately I instantaneously
get judged on my appearance that is very
frustrating for me so I'm gonna pick up
my hot water I'm gonna come over here
and I'm going to throw it right into my
bucket okay it means I have to work
harder but at the end it is so so
incredibly worth it
and one my name is dr. Kate B Bergdorf
and I am a lecturer at the University of
Texas at Austin I'm trying to break the
stigma of what a stereotypical scientist
looks like so my thing is I am not
wearing a bow tie I'm not wearing
suspenders I don't have some frumpy
cardigan on I'm just a regular girl who
likes to play with fire and I also
really like designer shoes and that's
okay
as the alginate hits the calcium
chloride the alginate would prefer to be
with the two plus charge calcium instead
of the one plus charge sodium and what
happens is we form gummy worms doesn't
matter what we look like any human can
be a scientist I definitely try to use
energy and excitement for food I do my
best to try to reach students that might
be intimidated by science I use anything
that will make the 483 students sit up
straight and actually listen to the
words coming out of your mouth as soon
as I've exploded something in their face
I have their attention for just 60
seconds and I can do whatever I can to
shove that knowledge right into their
brains
okay so what we're gonna do today is
doing some chemistry we're gonna do
three different hands-on experiments I
find chemistry to be an incredibly
challenging topic I am so sick of the
stereotypical female scientists and we
can do things other than biology by the
way chemistry physics engineering we can
do it the fact that I've been able to
master it but then use science to start
the conversation but then physically
stand there and break that image it's
the most rewarding thing I could ever do
ever
[Music]
another Nova Mary or doe the register
body
[Music]
carnival and muginami or to negate
Kabaddi is cornica body
[Music]
mera naam Chandra tomorrow Moretti for a
mess up super liver volume a pencil
humor canary Megan Leggett Oliver Gemara
Alton a Malaga we may build ilma both
cushy we taking per bar / averted aru
City Marathon Man or talk of Varginha
personal maker a Gurkha in the Kerwin
opossum Creek subsidy miracle no watch a
lot ahead of this Mary sub Danny be a
mime arbequina again cat right oh I'm
gonna tell ascertain when curry cream
medal the moody track a homeless already
said Jim a metal guitar Jim where Mary /
you are Wallach you say Matt surrender
you need an Emirati
to kill a kid you got any money
I'm knockin alegre-wood ashimelda
keyonna they color unlucky when they
were what they called Katara's wonderful
work alert his life became a Bob cook at
a vendor cubicle on video
Pellegrino bear give the debugger
sohcahtoa Munich or something
Nashville is a snob - pink are we
[Music]